[Musique]
bienvenue dans le duel des éditos votre
nouveau débat sur l'actualité politique
qui vous aide à y voir plus clair au
sommaire de cette première émission
jacques de guillebon et alexis poulain
débattent de l'autorité de l'état et de
la sécurité des français passer en
second plan avec la crise sanitaire le
thème est revenue au coeur de
l'actualité après le déplacement très
médiatique des manuels macron à
marseille et les violences commises
contre des policiers ces dernières
semaines l'idée que la police auraient
peur et que la république ne rentre pas
dans certaines cités elle est fausse
doublez la présence policière sur le
terrain ou encore près d'un milliard et
demi d'euros de budget en plus pour la
police ces annonces du président de
mercredi dernier ressemble un programme
de campagne pour 2022 y at il un
problème d'autorité de l'état en france
c'est le débat de la semaine jacques de
guillebon et alexis poulain décrypte
ensuite c'est de la primaire des
écologistes qui a commencé ce jeudi cent
vingt mille inscrits du jamais vu pour
une primaire écolo pour autant alors que
l'écologie est devenue un thème commun à
tous les partis à droite comme à gauche
les verts réussiront ils à attirer les
électeurs l'année prochaine c'est le
monde d'après mais pour commencer dans
l'acte eu des éditos alexis poulin et
jacques de guillebon s'attaque aux cases
et moore nouveau livre aux airs de
programmes suspension de son émission
sont ses news l'éditorialiste fait
énormément parler sans même avoir besoin
d'annoncer sa candidature pour 2022
d'ailleurs monsieur zemmour dans la
course à l'elysée ça profiterait à qui
bonjour alexis un jour jacques alors à
qui profiterait la candidature d'eric
zemmour mais j'aurais envie de répondre
à la france tout simplement pour
commencer ce serait un petit peu
partisan en tout cas la politique parce
que je pense qu'il relance le débat
aujourd'hui il rebat les cartes et jeux
pour repréciser la chose je pense pas
qu'ils profiteraient à emmanuel macron
en fait contrairement à ce que disent
les gens c'est à dire que le l'ennemi
juré des manuels accro à l'ennemi
préfère des manuela gross et marine le
pen c'est contre elle qu'il aura envie
d'être au second tour et eric zemmour
allait prendre des voix à marine le pen
et peut-être laissé passer la droite en
fait à sa place et dans ce cas-là macron
sera bien plus mauvaise posture que ce
qu'ils imaginent pour moi eric zemmour
il profite d'abord eric zemmour il est
en doute aux promos permanentes il est
là pour vendre son livre faire un tour
de france ensuite je suis assez d'accord
il profite à une refondation de la
droite il est là pour emmener la droite
un peu plus à droite mais je pense
qu'ils profitent quand même aussi à
emmanuel macron pas forcément dans
l'hypothèse d'un second tour mais dans
la capacité qu'a emmanuel macron de se
poser finalement en candidat du centre
alors qu'il va faire campagne à droite
et zemmour sera plus à sa droite qui
permettra à venelles macron de passer
pour le candidat de la raison où il ya
déjà marine le pen qui à droite en fait
ici eric zemmour fait baisser marine le
pen en fait c'est peut-être xavier
bertrand valérie pécresse qui va tirer
les marrons du feu et qui pourrait
menacer en fait emmanuel macron second
tour mais pour revenir sur le cas
zemmour c'est fascinant c'est que depuis
qu'il a été interdit par le csa
d'antenne en fait on ne parle que de lui
tout le temps est un peu lentilles
voldemort dans harry potter c'est à dire
il n'est pas là mais en prenant son nom
toute la journée il faut reprendre son
nom eric zemmour eric zemmour etc mais
cette décision du csa en fait elle est
quand même assez scandaleuse en fait et
je reviens qu'on regarde ce qu'on va y
arriver vous en faites dans une vidéo la
décision du csa a rendu inéluctable la
fin de l'émission c'était d'ailleurs
l'objectif poursuivi le gouvernement en
a rêvé le csa l'a fait le dernier
prétexte a consisté à me qualifier de
personnalités politiques en sachant très
bien que ce coup là serait fatal
depuis deux ans le csa a tout tenté mise
en demeure amende d'un montant
astronomique règles loufoques comme
cette obligation d'une émission en
différé
on est d'accord que eric zemmour en fait
est traité comme personne d'autre ne l'a
été dans le champ politique depuis des
années mais aussi peut-être parce qu'il
est lui-même disruptif un ovni ont
comparé au trump comme aux états unis
mais c'était la première fois depuis
très longtemps qu'un journaliste comme
ça qui n'est pas un homme politique va
sans doute déclaré sa candidature est en
tout cas fait des sondages à fait ceux
qui n'ont jamais été vus pour quelqu'un
qui vient d'arriver sauf peut-être
emmanuel macron mais qui était lui-même
déjà un politique je crois que le cas
zemmour évidemment il faut aussi arrêter
d'abord il faut rappeler que c'est une
carrière quand même dans la provocation
et la condamnation il a été cette fois
si tu es condamné deux fois une fois
c'était déjà en 2010 1 voilà ce qu'ils
disaient les employeurs ont le droit de
refuser des arabes ou des noirs condamné
pour provocation discrimination 2000
euros puis en 2016 dans le 6 septembre
tous les musulmans qui le disent ou
qu'ils ne le disent pas considère les
djihadistes comme des bons musulmans l'a
condamné cette fois ci pour provocation
à la haine religieuse on voit bien qu'il
ya chez zemmour quand même le fait de
faire avancer des idées racistes et
xénophobes et le racisme n'est pas une
opinion c'est un délit donc il faut
toujours rappeler regza moore que
parfois il n'est plus dans l'opinion
mais dans le délit ait été de 80 le
mieux j'aimerais juste finir là-dessus
dans une tribune au monde en 97 le
philosophe disait que a plus on va
parler de ces idées-là finalement plus
on va faire la promotion de ses idées là
alors qu'ils ne sont pas des idées
encore une fois c'est un délire
insistance pas du tout qu'eric zemmour
soit raciste ni se considèrent comme
telles en fait mais mais qu'encore une
fois la décision du csa elle elle ne
vient même pas là dessus elle vient sur
le fait qu'on interdise un éditorialiste
politique de parler alors qu'il n'est
même pas encore candidat alors que le
président du csa a reconnu didier
maistre disait exactement l inverse le
csa n'intervient jamais dans la
programmation des chaînes c'est ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire parce
qu'ils ont peur de l'empiré bolloré
parce qu'ils ont peur qu'on donne de la
voix à quelqu'un d'autre qu'à la gauche
ou causé entre autorisé en fait voilà
sur le sait ça je suis d'accord
d'ailleurs la taxe n'est pas nouvelle
puisqu'il avait condamné ces news à
200000 euros d'amendé pour incitation à
la haine et à la violence lorsqu'il
parlait des mineurs isolés où il disait
là que les mineurs isolés il comme le
reste de l'immigration n'ont rien à
faire ici ils sont voleurs ils sont
assassins il son violeur c'est tout ce
qu'ils sont le jugement va venir pour
l'eczéma moore en novembre là on a
encore à faire à une condamnation alors
que le cssa évidemment là et sciemment
choisi de museler eric zemmour parce
qu'il est d'une certaine façon candidat
non déclaré mais dans le champ politique
puisque ce livre ce tour de france ses
déclarations commence à orienter un eric
zemmour qui passerait de la case
polémiste à la case candidat mais on
peut comprendre ça veut dire qu'il ya
des idées qu'on a le droit d'exprimer en
fait et d'autres non
quand des journalistes de france inter
font des idées de gauche en fait je leur
dis pas qu'ils sont des historiques
politiques et qui font penser des six
défaites ayant droits il est pas
candidat mais il est en train il est sur
le chemin de la candidature d'un mur
[Musique]
c'est le moment du débat de la semaine
entre marseille et roubaix emmanuel
macron est omniprésent sur le thème de
la lutte contre l'insécurité depuis deux
semaines alors quel état des lieux de
l'insécurité en france l'autorité de
l'état est elle vraiment mise à mal
alexis poulin et jacques guilbaud en
débattent avec une première question
messieurs plus de flics mais plus friqué
c'est la bonne formule selon vous
alors plus de flics plus piqué je ne
sais pas si plus de flics ça veut dire
plus impliqué en tout cas clairement ce
problème de la sécurité de la police
aussi avec des destructions de postes
puis des créations de postes dans
l'impression qu'on fait n'importe quoi
depuis une trentaine d'années en france
c'est pas nouveau que ce soit nicolas
sarkozy ministre de l'intérieur qui
supprime des postes puis présidente qui
encore en supprimant remettre que ce
soit françois hollande qui décide d'en
être mais on est toujours dans un
problème en réalité en france je crois
de de la façon dont on aborde la
question sécuritaire et l'action de la
police police d'état or les problèmes
sont souvent au niveau d'une ville au
niveau d'un quartier haut niveau assez
de la proximité et les moyens qu'on
donne c'est toujours des chiffres que
que fait manuel macro game annonce 1,5
million milliards il annonce des cadeaux
des nouveaux uniformes etc mais qu'en
est il en réalité des moyens sur le
terrain doubler les bleus sur le terrain
comme il le dit lui même qu'est ce que
ça veut dire en réalité quand les
besoins sont pas forcément tous les
mêmes et que parfois peut-être que la
police nationale à cette limite là qu'on
devrait voir comment gérer au plus près
les besoins sécuritaires moi je pense
qu'elle surtout une question
philosophique derrière 24 son moral jeu
j'aime beaucoup cette phrase de bernanos
qui disait enlever un curé vous aurez
sans flics c'est à dire qu'en fait si on
a besoin d'être autant de fuites sur le
terrain aujourd'hui on le sait très bien
c'est parce que depuis 50 ans en fait
une destruction de la morale commune la
morale politique en france qui est dû en
grande partie à la gauche je pense quoi
et quand on fait des enfants des jeunes
gens qui ne sont plus éduqués et à qui
tout est permis en fait mais je pense
qu'il faut voir qu'il ya à mon avis
trois facteurs de la violence en france
aujourd'hui c'est d'abord les black
blocs afin qu'ils les antifas comme ils
s'appellent des anarchistes qui sont un
peu un épiphénomène qui vont dans les
manifestations se greffer comme des
parasites mais qui ont une haine de la
police et de l'ordre et de l'état mais
qui est logique avec leur avec leur
pensée philosophique qui sont déjà quand
même à la base en fait introduisent chez
les français cette pensée que le flic
est un ennemi et qu'il faut le détruire
il ya ensuite on l'a vu avec les jets
des jaunes sont minoritaires ils sont
minoritaires bien sûr de joueur serbe
est leur vider tout le monde déteste les
flics à kebab et cetera sont affichées
sur tous les murs et les instits en fait
ils sont plus minorité aujourd'hui qu'il
était il ya 30 ans mais il ya 30 ou 40
ans il y avait eu une veine du flic qui
était diffusée par cet anarchisme mais
en fait il faut pas se plaindre ensuite
cia
un petit peu de bordel qui arrivent
ensuite vous avez les gilet jaune qui
sont des plus tôt des sortes de
poujadiste comme qui sont des
manifestations sporadiques comme l'a dit
emmanuel macron mais qui sont qui
exprime une violence de ces classes
perdu périphériques qu'on a oublié et il
ya le troisième qu'on connaît
parfaitement qui est qui et la racaille
des banlieues en général des quartiers
comme ozzy qui est rappelons le aussi
souvent le fruit d'une certaine
immigration qui a été favorisée par la
gauche qui est elle même la gauche ne
leur a pas demandé de s'intégrer de
s'assimiler et d'avoir les mêmes moeurs
que les gens je sais qu'ils arrivaient
donc je pense qu'il faut pas oublier ça
déjà pour commencer en fête et se dire
pourquoi est ce qu'on a pour autant de
flics en fait qu'on ait autant flics et
s'amuse personnes en fait d'avoir des
flics partout dans la rue c'est une
réponse en fait à un état de fait qui a
été construit par une déconstruction
patience depuis 50 ans de tout ce qu'ils
pouvaient faire autorité quoi que ce
soit à l'école la famille lille d'état
ça c'est la vérité mais il faut voir
aussi que la réalité c'est que il ya
aussi sans doute une perte d'autorité
quand on voit sur les lits chiffres
qu'on va voir à l'écran le nombre de
policiers blessés a explosé alors qu'ils
sont en mission qu 140% c'est énorme les
gendarmes cus 30% et là le pire c'est
les pompiers les pompiers qui sont là
pour aider pour secourir pour être là
dans la dans la solidarité il est au
citoyen plus deux cent quatre-vingts
pour cent des cas d'agressions de
pompiers donc oui il ya un vrai problème
à la fois de de morale évidemment
puisque pourquoi attaquer un pompier
pourquoi attaquer un policier dans une
guerre de tranchées quasiment mais on
est aussi dans un certain déni du
politique j'aimerais qu'on écoute
emmanuel macron à marseille pour voir
comme le mal est profond il n'y a aucun
endroit dans marseille et en particulier
dans les quartiers nord
la police ne rentre pas ça n'existe pas
il ya des endroits où des situations
inacceptables pour les habitants existe
dès que vous avez le dos tourné dès que
vous repartez mais l'idée que la police
auraient peur et que la république ne
rentre pas dans certaines cités elle est
fausse et on va continuer vous donnez à
vous donner les moyens d'agir
de pilonner et de rendre certaines
situations irréversibles
voilà ces mots là quand même qu'ils sont
graves puisque finalement mails macro
est dans le déni de faire croire aux
policiers qu'ils peuvent aller partout
et un compte de magique afin de les
envoyer au front on va vous donner les
moyens d'agir de launay de rendre les
situations irréversibles ça veut dire
quoi qu'il cherche un affrontement total
les jours d'hui n'ont pas les moyens de
faire régner l'ordre dans certains
quartiers et on a l'impression que le
politique par la pensée magique parce
qu'il va doubler le nombre de policiers
va leur permettre de réaliser de
réaliser leur mission et je pense que ce
serait d'ailleurs s'ils cherchent
l'affrontement total en fait et y gagner
à la fin comme et il le dit lui-même à
marseille quand il continue il dit je ne
peux pas vous dire qu'on réussira je
mentirais si non en fait donc il est
conscient quand même que ce qu'il vient
de dire en fête est invité à mensonges
que c'est à dire d'un côté il dit la
police rentre partout mais il sait que
fait elle est désarmée aujourd'hui parce
que encore une fois ces quarante ans de
de désarmement et des gens qui ont un
sentiment d'impunité en fait ce qui est
dû notamment au trafic de drogue et tous
les trafics et à une certaine population
qu'on a aimé victimiser en fait de les
frire entend lui ne s'était jamais de sa
faute en fait que comme si on l'a gardé
dans un état infantile infante 1 et
qu'il fallait pas elle pas faire quoi
que ce soit contre ça et j on le
constate dans les chiffres enfin vous le
voyez depuis chaque année les chiffres
augmentent des chiffres des violences
gratuites surtout je vais revenir qu'on
voit les coups et blessures en fait des
trois derniers mois par rapport aux
trois mois précédents ont encore
augmenté de 12 % les vols pareil et en
bricolage les vols dans les véhicules en
fait ça ne fait qu'augmenter les luges
seulement la période du virus ou le
cambrioleur et l'agresseur lui même ne
pouvait pas sortir en fait que vous
savez c mais c'est continuer je pense
pas que ce soit le cas dans tous les
autres pays du monde et dans tous les
autres pays européens savoir qu'elle est
l'origine de cette violence et comment
on y répond encore une fois je pense
qu'il faut revenir à la racine en fait
et à l'éducation qui n'a pas été donnée
à ces personnes là ce n'est pas ça
n'arrive pas de nulle part en fait ce
sera pas d sont pas des agresseurs qui
descendent du ciel d'un du jour au
lendemain non il ya plusieurs choses de
la justice aussi est un une case
importante du dispositif l'éducation
évidemment les moyens donnés et la
police qui arrive en dernier recours
d'une certaine façon or là on en voit en
premier recours il ya un vrai problème à
la fois du déni du politique on le voit
d'ailleurs la sécurité c'est le point
faible des manuels lac rond depuis son
élection les français ne lui font pas
confiance ni sur la sécurité ni sur la
justice ils sont vraiment de vue pour
27% lui faire confiance il le sait un
set et un sondage il ya quelques mois
donc il est en campagne il prend ce
thème de la sécurité pour prendre les
devants et dire regardez moi j'ai mis
les moyens moi j'ai promis de recruter
j'ai fait un boulot de la sécurité je
répond aux attentes des policiers je
vais rassurer les français en disant que
je suis capable de faire quelque chose
mais on voit bien que c'est de la pensée
magique on en est très loin c'est
justement et ses conseillers il avait
avoué récemment dix ans en 2017 2016
quand on faisait campagne on pensait
qu'on allait vers une société de
bienveillance et que c'était uniquement
des questions d'économie un résulat
j'avais farid et que le par là tout se
passe rien dans la campagne et a pas de
questions de sécurité et que
l'enrichissement vous en faites allez
disons qu'on va libérer la croissance
servirait à régler tous les problèmes ce
qui est vraiment une pensée un des cils
je pense partagé par la gauche et par la
droite depuis depuis 40 ans de temps
c'est que là c'est uniquement de la
misère économique et social qui crée
cette violence alors qu'elle est
beaucoup plus profonde et le bourreau de
la sécurité oui dont on vous parlait en
fait accouché pour l'instant d'une d'une
souris on va leur donner plus de moyens
des plus belles voitures des cadeaux à
bel uniforme des caméras s'ils veulent
mais ce qu'attendent tous les policiers
à qui on parle sait on veut que la
justice en fait nous suivent et pour
l'instant on n'y a eu aucune réforme de
la justice il a annoncé des états
généraux de justice mais après quarante
mille places puis la justice évidemment
qui manque cruellement de moyens
d'ailleurs les n'ont pas de moyens mais
aussi de mauvaise volonté de chasser
aujourd'hui il ya aussi le fait d'un
sourire c'est compliqué d'ailleurs sur
sur la paperasse un dixième à des macros
il veut aller plus vite et simplifié
mais ça ne veut rien dire là encore une
fois qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que finalement on n'ira nulle part
on fera rien alors d'autres candidats
l'attaquent aussi comme xavier bertrand
sur le bilan sécuritaire en disant que
parce qu'il vient des beaux quartiers
d'amiens parce qu'il n'a jamais connu
finalement cette insécurité il ne
comprend pas cette thématique là c'est
le cas de beaucoup je me suis beaucoup
plus connue non exactement parce que
c'est une façon de se positionner mais
il ya une réalité aussi parce que quand
on parle de chiffres souvent vous avez
des think tanks qui vont vous dire oui
non mais alors en termes de sentiment
d'insécurité c'est un sentiment mais les
chiffres montrent que ça descend mais
quand vous êtes confrontés à
l'insécurité à la violence personnelle
c'est à la fois un traumatisme
psychologique qui a des répercussions
bien plus grave que même le fait d'aller
déposer plainte derrière c'est une perte
de confiance c'est parfois une perte
d'emploi c'est extrêmement complexe et
il devrait souvenir le sentiment
d'insécurité c'était l'argument des
socialistes en 2002 dès lors j'ai il ya
20 ans fait et qui ont fait perdre
lionel josse par là dessus par le refus
de la prise en compte de cette
insécurité moins l'impression que ça va
pas avancer en fait là que nicolas
sarkozy a fait le matamore comme
d'habitude en 2007 on va vous en
débarrasser et souvenez il s'est rien
passé françois hollande on connaît son
axe isme là dessus
dont les gones meilleur ami et et les
criminels traoré par exemple emmanuel
macron fait de puiser 3 4 ans maintenant
qu'il est au pouvoir n'a rien fait non
plus là dessus il ya darmanin qui a
encore agi de ses petits bras mais il
n'y a pas de pensée globale et manuela
kron a annoncé un plan sécurité sur 10
ans mais pour qu'un plan comptable en
fait pour dire ah oui la police 12
heures et ans et on va refaire votre
matériel * à une sympathique avancée
mais rien pour les rares mais
psychologiquement et rivera mais
psychologiquement c'est à dire il ya la
justice qui suit et les prisons aussi
comme vous le dites moi et ça ça ne suis
pas pour l'instant en fait vous allez
arrêter les criminels sont donné les
devants lorsque je pense qu'il faut agir
en amont évidemment et tout ça n ai pas
pensé et alors ce qui est le plus
étonnant depuis des années ce thème de
la sécurité revient comme un marronnier
il y avait un sondage qu'on a oublié
qu'ils étaient venus qui était de
l'observatoire national de la
délinquance et de la réponse judiciaire
qui datait de janvier février 2020 qui
parlait de 120 attaques au couteau par
jour et bien fin 2020 cet observatoire a
été dissous donc on aura pu les chiffres
on va arrêter d'en parler pour dire que
finalement le problème n'existe plus or
la sécurité c'est quelque chose qui est
dans la priorité des français depuis
toujours quelle que soit d'ailleurs le
bord politique alors c'est un peu plus
un peu moins à droite mais on voit bien
c'était un dernier sondage ifop encore
d'avril 2010 21 pour la majorité des
français 1 86% la sécurité sera
importante dans leur vote en 2022 donc
c'est bien pour ça je pense qu emmanuel
macron a fait ses promesses a fait le
boulot de la sécurité dans la foulée et
commence à faire en sorte que ce thème
là ne déborde pas trop parce que
évidemment il a aucun bilan en la
matière oui et il est débordé gérald
darmanin
à la radio encore avoué qu'il y avait
une marseillaise à sion des petites
villes et des zones rurales c'est à dire
que c'est non seulement les trafics qui
se répandent mais la violence qui va
avec il se répand partout en france et
chaque français peut le constater
maintenant c'est même plus à l'abri au
fin fond de la lozère en vous disant
j'ai pas de service public je connais
personne mais au moins je ne serai pas
agresser dans la rue ça se répand
partout et on l'a vu encore dans cette
ville fac est pas tout à fait dans une
zone rurale mais en tout cas une
banlieue à s'éloigner de pareilles val
de reuil récemment où je sais pas si
vous avez vu cette scène il y avait des
mariages qui était célébré à la mairie
et il ya une bande de l'ald et anaky la
ligue de défense noire africaine en fait
il ya débarqué que d'harmoniser les un
maillage qui a été dit c'est vrai que
j'en avais dit soudan depuis et qui est
débarqué en disant que le maire voulait
les grands remplacer qu'il y avait des
kurdes qu'ils aimaient pas dans la ville
bref ils sont venus troubler le trouble
et marié cette scène était hallucinante
envoyé une une pauvre adjointe au maire
ceinte de son écharpe en train d'essayer
d'arrêter cet ordre qui voulait rentrer
dans la mairie on sait pas trop pourquoi
on fait souvent de manière totalement
totalement insensibles ou adolescents
pour venir troubler des mariages de gens
qui n'en pouvaient mec était pas du tout
les gens qui ne cherchez donc et cette
violence permanente elle se répand
vraiment de plus en plus partout et je
pense que des français la voix et c'est
pour ça que pour revenir à notre sujet
précédent je pense que des gens comme
marine le pen ou eric zemmour ont un
tapis rouge devant eux s'il n'y a pas de
réaction de le reste de la classe
politique au fait et cette réaction est
toujours blessé par luc mélenchon donc
on entend jamais parler là dessus qu'il
va réagir oui et puis il ya aussi le
fait que une certaine forme de
délinquance est en train a pu baisser
alors que effectivement la violence
gratuite ce type d'agression n'a fait
qu'augmenter avec ce sentiment difficile
et puis aussi on en parlait en
introduction la confiance dans la police
alors ça c'est vrai que c'est un vrai
problème au delà des black blocks dont
c'est le fond de commerce mais on a vu
quand même lors des mobilisations du
gilet jaune lors des manifestations à
répétition déjà donné la loi travail que
la police avait monté d'un cran aussi
dans la réponse est là on a tous les
problèmes des gens qui ont perdu un oeil
perdu une main ces violences qu'on a
appelée policière violences policières
et on a mis des mois à en parler l'igpn
maintenant qui est remis en question
enfin pas vraiment mais qui veut être
chapeauté par un organisme parlementaire
pour enquêter sur la police et puis les
débordements la mc2 nancy notamment oui
mais des policiers raciste qui qui a qui
étaient là c'est le rêve que la gauche
qui voit son qui veut son georges floyd
en fait pour dire regardez tous liés à
une tous les policiers saura si c'est de
leur faute violences policières etc mais
et ne vous étonnez pas de quoi sa liste
à la fin et je pense que la france
insoumise et c'est toute cette gauche là
et collabos fait complice du fait que
les gens ya aujourd'hui se croit permis
et légitime d'insulter les flics de leur
taper dessus non alors que les flics
sont là généralement tous les protéger
et ne peut pas demander oh oui d'accord
mais sienne violences policières je
pense qu'elle est une réponse en fait à
cette violence de la société ni
antérieur il ya évidemment
une échelle de la violence une escalade
le problème c'est que la police en tant
que service public en tant
qu'institution doit être irréprochable
or on a vu des dérives qui n'ont pas été
pris en temps et en heure je parle de la
bac de nancy ces fameux groupuscule
d'extrême droite qui se moquer de leurs
collègues qui tu es
il fallait agir en amont il fallait
aussi dire un moment bon on ne peut pas
tolérer ça dans la police tout comme les
enquêtes officielles ont avalé plus bien
c'est que ces minuscules mais vous aurez
sans doute votre maudit coup c'est qui
n'est vous serez content en fait j'avais
contacté par il y aura plus de politique
sécuritaire mais c'est pas une question
de violence ou de mort par le fait de la
police c'est une question de respect de
l'institution on est d'accord mais je
pense que c'est
minuscule en fait c'est sérieux tous
infinitésimale sur ce qu'est la police
en général pas et ce qu'est le reste de
la violence dans la société c'est mon
avis le plus important
[Musique]
place au monde d'après petite info et
bruits de couloir jacques de guillebon
et alexis poulain vous dévoile ce que la
politique des jours à venir nous réserve
la primaire des écologistes s'est lancé
ce jeudi en lice l'eurodéputé yannick
jadot le maire de grenoble eric piolle
l'ancienne vice-présidente de la région
au de france sandrine rousseau
la députée delphine batho et
l'entrepreneur jean marc governatori
cinq candidats et plus de 120 mille
inscrits cette fois plus qu'en 2016
messieurs on ouvre les paris quels sont
vos pronostics
alors c'est très difficile de faire un
pronostic mais je pense que ça va être
l'élection peut-être la plus drôle de
l'année en fait cette primaire des verts
on a 120 mille inscrits on sait pas d'où
ils sortent y en avait dix fois moins en
fait à la dernière primaire en 2016 même
si on n'allait plus à la précédente ce
qui n'est pas grand chose encore son ami
la primaire de la droite en 2016 y avait
4 millions d'inscrits sunu nous en met
sa montre en tout cas soit que la
question écologique est rentré dans
l'esprit des gens ce qui est logique vu
le lavage de cerveau qu on qu'on subit
et la greta qu'une des réalisations du
monde en fait est en marche soit il ya
des hordes de troll on pourrait dire
qu'ils se sont inscrits pour essayer de
de truquer cette élection peut-être
julien bayou qui est donc le patron de
élevé le 10 et le 13 septembre 91 % des
inscrits ne sont pas issus des six
partis organisateurs ce que ce sont six
parties organisées çà et donc ils ne
savent pas du tout qui est cette
population donc soit ça leur prédit
peut-être qu'ils vont gagner l'élection
présidentielle et qui vont faire 25 %
mais c'est parce que dans les sondages
pour l'instant sur jadot soit c'est la
curiosité soit c'est du trollage on va
peut-être avoir une merveilleuse
sandrine rousseau ou un jean marc
governatori qui va être leur candidat
est dense qu'elle serait très amusant
alors avec les verts c'est ça qui est
exceptionnel c'est que c'est toujours
une surprise s'est jamais le candidat
auquel on pense qui sort des urnes alors
on peut pas rejeter les verts et dire
que après tout ils jouent le jeu de la
prom la primaire c'est un vrai parti
démocratique puisque plusieurs parties
sont lassés il ya eu des vraies de
refaire la démocratie une marche guidée
journée non mais peu importe mais il ya
des vrais débats d'idées quand même et
il ya des candidats qui se sont
démarqués avec la petite phrase un
sandrine rousseau notamment qui a fait
beaucoup parler d'elle qui a permis de
prendre des parts de marché d'une
certaine façon de faire connaître aussi
ce courant là et eric piolle qui qui
était peu connu du grand public qui
monte en tant que maire de grenoble mais
plus encore maintenant je serais
incapable de vous dire qu'il va sortir
du chapeau de cette primaire des écolos
mais beaucoup de parties attendent de
savoir parce que en tout cas ce qui
coûtera l'alliance je pense pas qu'un
candidat vert pourra gagner la
présidentielle où se retrouver au second
tour en revanche il peut changer la
donne pour le second tour et c'est là
que tout le monde regarde un peu pour
voir à gauche qu'est ce qui va se passer
à gauche un puisque non ici à droite on
regarde aussi avec intérêt puisque
sandrine rousseau est devenu la star de
la droite et l'extrême droite et c'est
assez un show nue donc du rassemblement
national l'a dit il a été depuis exclu
de la primaire mais c'était un ce qu'ils
voulaient voter il s'était inscrit en
fait en dix ans en général le vote est
secret mais par solidarité nordiste je
ne peux que voter pour sandrine rousseau
va donc ça a été très mal pris
évidemment par les verts qu'ils ont a
priori exclue de de son vote en fait ce
qui est assez étrange d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas très démocratique puisque vie
la beauté qui s'était ouvert à tout le
monde à win or il semble utile il avait
signé la charte de dévers fâche pas
comment il a fait d'ailleurs mais oui ce
parti en fait et encore une fois
l'expression d'un pas d'un démocratisme
ou plus distant sait pas trop où il va
il n'y a pas de chef je crois pas que
les dégâts de rechange tout le temps il
ya une adhésion en fait global de la
population évidemment la question
écologique qui voudrait que la planète
soient saccagés et commence demain mais
c'est tout ça est hanté par
du bushisme de plus bas étage d'où vous
qui sont pas des choses comme ça qui
reviennent dans les paroles notamment de
de sandrine rousseau qui viennent
pourrir en fait et pervertir le le
premier schéma est la première volonté
qu'ils avaient choix que de problèmes d
des écologistes c'est qu'ils ont gagné
d'une certaine façon le débat d idées
tout le monde ne parle plus d'écologie
quand on est candidat que ce soit au
niveau européen au niveau national à
l'international il faut faire quelque
chose pour le carbone pour sauver la
planète entre guillemets surtout sauver
l'espèce humaine d'une certaine façon ou
d'une autre le problème c'est que eux
ils sont scindés en plusieurs 50 nuances
de vert on va dire est que c'est très
compliqué de savoir où se positionner et
comment devenir du coup un candidat
crédible ce qu'essaye de faire yannick
jadot mais du coup il est vu comme trop
à droite
et donc c'est extrêmement compliqué
cette démocratie interne mais aussi une
fois qu'on va défendre les idées écolo
quand tout le monde se veut écolo et je
crois que c'est ça en fait la limite des
verts aujourd'hui elle est dans le fait
que l'écologie n'est plus un sujet en
tant que tel il est devenu objet qui
infuse toute la vie politique d'une
façon là ni anne hidalgo est aussi écolo
qu en fait et ce qu'on a retenu en fait
2 lors de leur débat c'est pas du tout
leurs propositions écologiques péril
sont les phrases justement périphériques
celle de sandrine rousseau governatori
et ses fins et et/ou seller wheeler
gauchisme mais ils n'ont pas de
propositions faites écolo qui soit
supérieure à celle des autres partis en
fait à part peut-être delphine batho qui
a prôné la décroissance larhant je
trouve assez sympathique et si je devais
voter peut-être que je voterai pour elle
en fait mais mais pour le reste oui ils
sont devenus enfin c'est comme c'est
comme s'ils avaient un parti je sais pas
de l'éducation nationale en fait par
exemple monde éducation nationale selon
les accords sanaa
mais en tout cas ça fait très amusant je
pense bien sûr la question
écologistes c'est vrai qu'il y ait un
avant et un après great attenberg hier
un sondage récemment dans le hall 1 de
cette planète qui était qu'elles sont
des dix mille jeunes de france etats
unis australie inde et 75 % des jeunes
sont angoissés de l'avenir ils pensent
que l'avenir va être noir il ya près
d'un jeune sur deux qui pensent ne pas
faire d'enfant et et tout le monde voit
que finalement l'espèce humaine est
condamné je pense qu'il ya il faut
dépasser cette écologie qui fait peur ou
qui alertent tant mieux et c'est la
pause 50 ans dallaire climatique il
serait temps de la prendre au sérieux
mais il faut agir il faut pas simplement
être angoissé sur l'avenir donc
j'espère et je pense que les verts sont
en train de changer ils vont peut-être
avoir des messages autres que ceux ci et
qu'on va aller beaucoup plus loin cette
primaire là c'est peut-être la première
étape d'un d'une autre écologie oui bien
sûr je pense que c'est
c'est en fait ils sont un peu suicidaire
en fait aussi pour l'instant c'est à
dire que s'ils veulent plus l'enfant ils
ont plus d'électeurs en fait dans dans
20 ans fait est qu'ils sont en train de
tuer l'écologie un petit peu en fait en
ne laissant rien du tout ça on verra en
tout cas il reste beaucoup de choses à
faire après la primaire c'est l'élection
présidentielle on verra si on aura un
candidat vert au premier ou second tour
c'est la fin du duel des éditos vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre site rt france point tv
et en podcast sur toutes les plateformes
vous pouvez également réagir dans les
commentaires et sur les réseaux sociaux
via le hashtag ldd eux à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau duel des
éditos
[Musique]